I honestly can't remember the last time
such a hit show had this fire of a
reunion with all the major players
coming back so thank you that 90s show
for changing that are you the cops
looking for a movie yes we are Mila
Kunis she was surprisingly so
uncomfortable doing scenes with Ashton
Kutcher Laura Prepon shed tears pretty
much immediately things got wild on set
this is how we do it not only is it
packed with 90s Nostalgia but it's also
full of secrets you gotta show them the
life though this is what people don't
know daytime night time it's all an
illusion who else is trying to get in on
being part of this live studio audience
this is our perspective you guys don't
see what happens behind the scenes who
needs a laugh track anyway there are
also a few hidden gems hidden throughout
the set that you might not have noticed
no I'm not talking about Eric's gone
just ash from the 70s but I'm I'm taking
a trip down to the basement this couch
was in the original show the living room
yes the basement furniture from the
original That 70s Show living room even
Red's armchair made its way down that
classic wooden table had seen a whole
lot of smoke sessions if you look
closely at the bookshelf in the living
room you'll see some original photos
from That 70s Show it's like a little
reunion every episode
let's find out if I might even knock it
was on this like no time passed Deborah
Joe Kitty says being back on set was a
total gift emotions were running super
high but I'll get into all those tiers
that were shedding a bit Deborah Joe
said that little Mila Kunis actually
talked to her about her first kiss on
set with Ashton maybe she saw the spark
of Love even back then I remember
Mila's first kiss was Ashton it's crazy
just how well that went I remember
thinking oh my god well at least he's
cute you know that's good I can always
count on Kitty for some Stellar motherly
advice and
his favorite character on That 70s Show
was Kitty whenever things are going bad
we just throw it over to Deborah Jones
she and she does that she goes Deborah
Joe spends a lot of time in the makeup
chair because of her wig for real nearly
every character has one M's cutie
and there we go she had all the best
lines in That 70s Show you know Donna
I've been drinking kurtwood Smith red
said he hardly gets any funny lines
because they all just go to her I get no
jokes I help you I help you be funny
that's true it's like these two have
been married for 20 years or something
you knew it was coming Michael
truly iconic I love being them together
but Mila Kunis actually had another idea
for Jackie's love interest I called BS
team Fez or team Kelso either way Jackie
and Kelso continue there on again
off-again Trope by getting remarried
again in that 90s show One's Gonna stick
right yeah
and you'd think Milo would be pretty
relaxed filming with her husband yeah
not so much I was more nervous doing
that than anything else in my career was
to shoot with my husband this time
around Mila's nerves were because of
just how close she and Ashton were at
this point I'd be like oh my God that's
what you look like when you act there
was also this super meta Vibe about
being married and stepping onto the
exact same set they met on all those
years ago and it looks the same was
trippy oh my God speaking of trippy
everyone had a super emotional responses
to being back on set tears were shed
hugs were exchanged and improv was
created that moment when Eric and Donna
are sitting in the foreman driveway and
push each other's head that was a call
back to the original show that wasn't in
the script they just slipped back into
their old characters like nothing which
was probably why nearly everyone was
crying like Laura Prepon Deborah Joe the
showrunners even broke down after seeing
how trippy the old new set was oh and
there's this throwback to costumes who
else is looking for some of these Styles
fun fact Ashton Kutcher kept his old
Kelso costume and sent videos to Greg
metler the original and current writer
of him running around his house wearing
the Kelso costume annoying Mila Kunis
and yelling damn Jackie damn Jackie will
you just give me a minute to enjoy this
Ashton fell asleep in the foreman
basement practicing his lines and said
one of the strangest feelings of his
life was waking up to Mila standing over
him dressed as Jackie he was like what
year is it right now the showrunner said
bringing back specific wardrobe pieces
and of course the Vista Cruiser were
very important for that 90s Show the
cast even had some input in what was
placed around the set they had all taken
props from the original set and they
brought them back for the reunion
Deborah Joe brought back the glass
grapes that sat on Kitty's table and
those OG cast photos on the bookshelf
Peep and Tom Poston Kitty's parents
Wilmer brought back his Fez accent which
he hadn't done since That 70s Show ended
the Vista Cruiser and some original Fez
wardrobe pieces think you could spot
them what are you talking about is this
a joke anyone else wish they were in a
smoke Circle in the foreman basement
right now yeah I guess re-watching the
show will have to suffice for now with
all of the major 70s players coming back
the OG set pieces and props and The Meta
Love Story Mila Kunis and Ashton Kutcher
gave us that 90s show is definitely on
the books for an upcoming classic what
do you think too much Nostalgia is that
even possible let us know in the
comments